- You kept saying there
was blood on your hands.
- Was there?
- Couldn't say, yeah, every
time I looked at your hands,
all I could see was lobsters.
Where'd you go, old sport?
Sport.
Tell me, sport.
Sport!
Indecent exposure,
that's a really good title for something,
it kind of rolls of the tongue.
You know I actually have this killer idea
for a psychological thriller,
set in the world of "Celebrity Rehab."
- (chuckles) Let me guess,
an addiction councilor turns
out to be a celebrity stalker?
- Holy shit!
I think you just cracked
it, are you a writer?
It's like Promises in
Malibu but with fake people.
Love's buns, am I right?
- [Will Voiceover] Well that's
accidentally horrifying.
- Your sisters very talented.
- Annapurna actually, is set to produce
and my dear friend, Daniel Day-Lewis,
is attached to this dope
pitch I've been kicking around
but DDL's oeuvre is not
about that four-quadrant
hero's journey bullshit.
So I'm, like, birthing the scenes
instead of impaling myself on the rocks
of a three-act structure.
You had that look like when
Keanu sees the black cat.
How 'bout we move the woman's lit display,
like why are we separating?
That's sexist, right?
Why should it always be
the woman keeping track
of shit like that?
Feminism!
And when it looks so
cute you wanna fuck it,
holla at your boy, namaste.
Can't be here, okay, I
like need some matcha.
Besides, I heard this is
how Toni Morrison does it.
- What?
- She's, like, a very famous
black chick who writes books?
- I know who fucking Toni Morrison is,
I highly doubt she writes at gun point!
- Oh, no, no, no, I just meant
that she writes in hotels.
Retract the claws less you
scratch yourself with hypocrisy.
Is it bisexual pescatarian
week again already?
You're not one of those
self-loathing Jews, are you?
- What?
- Joe Goldberg, great name for a producer,
Will Bettelheim, made
you sound like a Nazi.
Sweet, you are so fucking money
and you don't even know it.
Oh, are you gonna puke?
'Cause that's totally
fine, just not over here,
it's antique camel hair on demo.
Did you know Ja Rule and
Ashanti never banged?
I will make a film that premiers
Sundance 2020 at the
Eccles, Friday night slot.
Then goes on to sweep the Gothams,
winning two, no, three
Indie Spirit awards.
Fuck the Oscars.
Before anybody asks, Amy
picked me up from a meeting
where I found new sponsor.
Can't name names but let's just
say the Academy robbed him.
Would you fuck me?
Come on, you would totally fuck me.
Take this.
Give it to Delilah and when
you fuck her, you think of me.
We were both reaching for the queso
and it was like this
insane, destiny moment.
Can you tell me if this
Carl Young book is vegan?
Dude, I love green juice but celery
is basically Satan's butt plug.
We take the auditions on the road,
look for our Scarlett O'Hara.
He spent two years traversing Asia
so he could sprinkle James'
ashes all over the Himalayas
and now he's back,
traversing Love's vagina.
I would poltergeist the shit
out of him if I was James.
♪ Amy, Candace. ♪
I was just thinkin',
we never got to live out
our spectrophilia fantasy.
Ours is a forbidden love
but mama ghosts, right?
I mean I will be in and out
and you won't even know it.
I mean, you'll definitely know it.